hello there
reject nation I'm Greg I'm John we are
going to watch a a 24 and a 24 a 24 and
a 24 film in fabric I always look
forward to a 24 films because they do
weird stuff before we go into that thank
you to all you beautiful little [ __ ]
who have been following us on the
Stardust app you [ __ ] are doing the
right choice and yet horndogs
I cannot wait for you guys to post 30
second reaction reviews for any film TV
show or trailer and we post daily - it's
completely free to download and use
let's participate in this orgy together
old school
[Music]
horizon thank you the hesitation in your
voice
soon to be an echo in the recesses of
the spheres of retail
the dress is your image come to what you
project to an illusion
just going on a date I don't normally
wear this kind of thing be bold
your day to accompany menu I would like
you to announce the number to your
telephone oh one six three two
and stuff as promised different ago sure
everything's fun
what's your machine
[Music]
it's just a cheap bit of mystery is
something depressed
don't tell me scared address
[Music]
it's definitely borrowing from some
giallo Argento stuff yeah weird the
sounds and the weird lights and the
weird like jump cuts superimpositions
and stuff that was fun
yeah it looks wild I'm excited hey lore
dress yeah and then we gotta have a
marathon with rubber and see which one
holds up better yeah and then throw in
killer condom - I have like all these
quotes from really reputable top critics
here yeah they I'm surprised this film
specifically is getting this much great
feedback hey man when you go out there
you catch a lot of people's eyes and
ears that looks so strange I know
hey I don't I mean I'm not really
familiar with this directors other work
but you know maybe they've got a
masterful grip on the surreal you know I
love one of these where yeah things
start out ostensibly normal and then one
pretty yeah it's like evil dress is such
a weird idea but I gotta imagine you
know if this movie is firing on all
cylinders they'll probably be some
pretty wild and strange subtexts going
on to match you know with the giallo
style I got imaginative a24 back this
there's gotta be something going on
under the hood besides you know a
tribute to that style god I have killer
underwear it's always just making things
grow bigger yeah yeah it's really
unmanageable it's really crazy people
are like whoa Craig do something you
gave me a haircut no it's the underwear
no it's a giant genitalia in my pants
making overconfidence
yeah sued out of me plus you know if you
need to take care of somebody you just
plop it on their head and then their
head swells and bursts you know you can
murder people with your killer underwear
I hope they don't explore any lower I
hope they don't explore any mythology in
here yeah I never explained how any of
this is happening well don't if you do
it's actually gonna ruin it gotta have
that air of mystery but then I want
there to be a bunch of fandom related
articles really dissecting and
theorizing what this dress means this
kind of
Pano's cosmatos Karamazov his style a
little bit of a lynchin
anything that feels just so cerebral
surreal just very trippy it's weird that
they build this at least in the little
ads I saw leading up to this trailer was
like Gwendoline Christie horror movie
and I'm like she's only in one shot
third it doesn't look like she is in
anyway the focus here usually enough to
sell people I don't know I know I've
seen the woman who plays the lead in
something else before and it's cool that
she gets to lead this you know it seems
like to have the story centered around a
woman of color to just is like a nice
thing to see for something like this I
guess what jaws did for people going
into the water in fabric is gonna do for
women when they buy dresses I mean I'm
actually really excited to see what this
movie wants to do and what it wants to
get at because you know I can only
imagine what that metaphor must be for a
dress is like a second skin in its own
way plus you know they're not what
they're trying to say I don't know what
they're trying to say cuz I've seen the
movie but I don't know I'm guessing that
you know there are lots of things you
could probably assert like yeah maybe it
is you know the right dress can or the
right outfit of any kind can imbue
confidence and there's an internal
feeling that comes of it but there's
also external feelings and attentions
that come of that the pageantry of
dressing up for people and stuff like
that and also like her dates like he
hands her like a really limp flower and
the date you know perhaps doesn't seem
to be going at least according to plan
so I don't know I mean you know lying
between what you try to project with
your fashions or whatever versus who you
really are
I feel like if it's a again he said I
don't know like six times because I use
a lot of ideas I know I'm spitballing
guessing that these could be themes
they're gonna explore or something no no
no that's true seven times but yeah and
all seriousness to get what you're
getting at in terms of whatever metaphor
that can come from it I mean they like
one critic says a movie about a killer
dress I've heard that phrase used that's
a killer outfit as a killer dress and to
make something quite literal and they do
have a hint at some mythology here where
some guy is saying like he's reading
from something of those who wear me know
me know me you know the dog
attacking and maybe there's some like
evil spirit and dude in there I'm hoping
this takes a good amount of time to
really slowly build into mayhem I want
it to be one of those experiences where
I'm halfway through going is any of that
[ __ ] in the trailer gonna happen and
then it starts going mad of just someone
who just goes shopping one day yeah it
finds the stress and they hey you know
like that's the right kind of outfit can
make you feel a certain kind of way make
you feel very confident make you feel
like and that energy exudes out so it
makes you more attractive then slowly
and very slow it starts to crumble you
know I want that layer in there I feel
like at the end of the day I might not
fully understand everything this movies
about it that's tends to be what a 24 is
weird horror movies are thank you wrong
like what was that about exactly yeah I
mean everything you're describing is
kind of everything that seems in
tradition with both David Lynch as well
as giallo filmmaking in general because
you go back and you watch you know
Suspiria or any of those old Argento
movies and stuff like they're usually
they're wild and crazy but they do take
a good amount of time and you do live I
mean they're out of a different era so
also just the approach to pacing was
different but I got imagine that this
will spend a fair amount of time it
looks pretty intimate with the lead
character at the very least I mean this
is kind of a chaotic trailer but I also
know the finale
yeah or the dream sequences yeah
supposed to be very hypnotic and that's
why I think the slow bill works as it
puts you into the zone of this world
yeah when it makes you wonder how deep
it all goes because like not only is the
dress strange in its own way but also
you have like this woman at the
department store who is like announcing
her phone number numbers out and is like
just surreal in her own rights that I'm
like is this some kind of weird store
that doesn't the people one of those
they have that ending shot of everyone
just standing there lined up hosing yeah
is this like a needful things kind of
thing where it's like you come into the
store and get what you need but but not
quite something's amiss you know
well the fashion industry you know I
feel like what do you
is completely humane as well-adjusted
yeah and accepting of all the kinds of
people the idea of who they want you to
be like seems to always factor into
these like horror fashion movies because
fashion always provides you with an
aspiration you know yeah like dressing
up your your yeah you're propping up
that's fun are you excited for in
Suspiria with this come in fabric the
latest movie from the 1970s below before
we wrap this video up I would like to
give a patron of the day shout out to a
woman named Jenna
Randolph Jenna my dear we've been
talking back and forth she's gonna be
going to the Comic Con near her town
very very soon she's gonna hang out with
Sean Astin or at least snap a photo with
him no you gotta hang out with Sean a
kidnap Sean Astin throw them in the back
of a truck you just got yourself a brand
new job congratulations
I suggest you know if you're gonna be
working in the back doing all that
legwork you know what make things better
what John a new dress a new dress a new
sexy dress which you want is to have
just constant sexual appeal amongst the
few co-workers who can see you because
that will always make for just wonderful
easy to go dynamics and if they come on
to you you go quit being a perv I just
like wearing this dress that's your
right man just you know carry a Taser
with you to work or a gun or sure yeah
whatever you need to feel secure bring a
gun everyday to this apartment I mean I
don't leave it here go out every morning
job go to my box and get my gun and then
you put it away every time I leave it's
the weirdest thing